poco más de 3 años después de la muerte
de Jamal Khashoggi periodista Saudita
asesinado el 2 de octubre de 2018 en el
consulado Saudí de Estambul uno de sus
presuntos asesinos Khalid al Octavia ha
sido detenido hoy mismo en París a por
la petición de extradición de Turquía
para juzgar a los presuntos asesinos del
periodista Saudita asesinado hace 3 años
ha anotado y según muchas fuentes
adentro del gobierno turco y también de
la Unión Europea y de Naciones Unidas
fue parte del comando asesino que viajó
desde Riaza a Turquía a Estambul para
detener al Saudí y asesinarlo en el
mismo momento que entrase en el
consulado Saudí en Estambul según muchos
recuentos que público la prensa turca
través de fuentes anónimas dentro del
gobierno turco a Javi fue interceptado
en el mismo momento de entrar
descuartizado dentro del consulado y
después su cuerpo sigue sin aparecer
después de 3 años ahora lo traigo y se
presenta una situación difícil para para
este ciudadanos cuyo gobierno asegura
que no tiene nada que ver con este
asesinato de hecho gobierno saudí dice
que todos los culpables de este
asesinato en seguida encausados y
condenados algo que la Unión Europea y
la Naciones Unidas considera que ha sido
un juicio farsa pero ahora mismo al
otaibi se presenta ante la sensación que
mañana mismo el fiscal deberá decidir
sobre su futuro sigues extraditado y su
caso es percibido como correcto y es
extraditado a Turquía para ser juzgado
dentro del caso que está ocurriendo en
Estambul o si su caso rechazado y ahora
y se permitirá que al otro viaje árabe
Saudí como eso que está intentando volar
desde París árabes audio y mismo mañana
podría volver a hacerlo en el caso de
que la Fiscalía francesa decretarse que
no tiene nada que ver con el caso